this is London His Majesty King George
the sixth
[Music]
let us remember the men in all the
services are the women and all of the
services who have laid down their lives
we have come to the end of our
simulation and they are not with us at
the moment of our words I see I speak to
you today the same are as my father did
exactly 75 years ago his message then
was a salute to the men and women at
home and abroad who had sacrificed so
much in pursuit of what he rightly
called a great deliverance the war had
been a total war it had affected
everyone and no one was immune from its
impact whether it be the men and women
called up to serve families separated
from each other or people asked to take
up new roles and skills to support the
war effort all had a part to play at the
start the outlook seemed bleak the end
distant the outcome uncertain but we
kept faith that the cause was right and
this belief as my father noted in his
broadcast carried us through never give
up never despair that was the message of
VE Day I vividly remember the jubilant
scenes my sister and I witnessed with
our parents and Winston Churchill from
the balcony of buckingham palace the
sense of joy in the crowds have gathered
outside and across the country
was profound there were we celebrated
the victory in Europe we knew there
would be further sacrifice it was not
until August that fighting in the Far
East ceased and the war finally ended
many people laid down their lives in
that terrible conflict they
for say we could live in peace at home
and abroad they died so we could live as
free people in a world of free nations
they risked all so our families and
neighborhoods could be safe we should
and will remember them as I now reflect
on my father's words and the joyous
celebrations which some of us
experienced firsthand I'm thankful for
the strength and courage that the United
Kingdom the Commonwealth and all our
allies displayed the wartime generation
knew that the best way to honor those
who did not come back from the war was
to ensure that it didn't happen again
the greatest tribute to their sacrifice
is that countries who were once sworn
enemies are now friends working side by
side for the peace health and prosperity
of us all today it may seem hard that we
cannot mark the special anniversary as
we would wish instead we remember from
our homes and our doorsteps
but our streets are not empty they are
filled with the love and the care that
we have for each other and when I look
at our country today and see what we are
willing to do to protect and support one
another I say with pride that we are
still a nation those brave soldiers
sailors and airmen would recognize and
admire I send my warmest good wishes to
all